this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the reaction
people what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we are going to watch two
episodes of Scott Pilgrim today episode three
and four we're going to start double uping for
reasons that are pretty obvious ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead and leave a like
on this video that would mean the world also be
sure subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notified when our reactions for the next
episodes of Scott Pilgrim reactions up here
on the Chanel thank you to prep for helping
us edit down these highlights as always a big
thank you saw a good amount of you guys did
join our patreon page for Scott Pilgrim fing
through at and watch alongs where you single
with your own copy so we cover several things
over there exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included guys let's get into
it that's a flower like Ramona Flowers and a fly
buzzing by to Signal symbolize death Young Neil's
bedroom oh young Neil's a screenplay
Rider at my roommate's band maid's
funeral thinking what if I can die and just
when I found out I'm a copile anyways that's
why I'm busy writing this movie so don't
bother calling the late inspiration ends
becoming a writer oh yeah he's got the fight
club poster oh inspiration struck oh scream
I've written
nothing and it's
autobiographical O Beautiful shot mad
Madness oh AI chaty BT in physical manifestation
that's what the robots want my sleep paralysis de
demon wow if my sleeper
alysis demon could write me a
screenplay written by Young Neil the hell is
going on in this show I wrote a feature like
screenplay on my sleep I'm a screenwriter F
it's all it takes your Prodigy man just takes
one just takes the right software
you know it's how good final draft
is oh die again the morning phase is
passed sounds oo like a flame it's always
that same look yeah it's always that umbre
thing Bona rents a video I'll be returning
some videotapes you changed your hair what's
up Ramona nothing major just somebody
kidnapped Scott Pilgrim and faked his
death you're [__] joking bringing back the
censoring tell me everything last night in
my dreams I saw Scott's Subspace Highway
they do communicate in this like dream
plane oh no that astral I think it means
he's alive he's a force ghost so I went
back to the rocket to look at the security
footage of what we thought was Scott's death
cops couldn't figure this out
nope
whoa someone grabbed him and pulled him into a
portal it took you going through the security
camera footage to nobody had a right vantage
point to see that I knew it was too good to be
true your sugar daddy days are over for
him absolutely for others we'll see the
future is a mystery oh only Ramona
seems sad that Scott's missing don't
tell me you're going to try to find him
I think I have to detective flowers you
went on one date how good could it have
been honestly great your date with Scott
pilgram a I thought you could give me a quick
rundown of the major characters in Scott's
life more like major suspects yeah there's Steven
Stills my ex the singer in the band he's a mess I
don't remember them used they used to date I don't
remember that there's Steven's roommate Young Neil
he's kind of sheltered and he's only 19 but don't
let that fool you he's a copile what about Envy
Adams Envy Adams pulled Scott's heart out of his
F and stomped all over it with her patent leather
combat boots I saw her do her thing at the funeral
she's even hotter in person true are we sure they
dided you're obviously not the only one with
questionable taste Ramona now having that film
new warm fatal quality in the first episode
suddenly makes sense you know who you should
talk to his other ex what is sex bomb without
Scott that looks good what if we find a new bass
player and they make us worse the odds are they'd
make us better because we probably sucked there's
always Scott's understudy knives which join how
long have you been playing the drums a long time
since I was 14 drumming's a great outlet for
my emotions what a that random realistic far
away there you go double
down oh hell yeah getting in the zone oh hell
yeah take L to care with the instrumentation
animation look at you jamming together
what a beautiful Lucid experience you
could be one of those bands where it's
just two people and one of them plays
bass someone plays drums and sings
it's perfect Death from Above 1970
knives wow you're better how long have you
been playing bass what time is it 400 p.m.
then 4 hours I'm late for work you ever thought
about collaborating with a seasoned songwriter
uh uh-oh what do you know they used to date
right and Scott used to date her the drummer
in the movie at least I think that was in
her first episode Chiron after to refresh
funny thought maybe he faked his own death to get
out of paying his late fees he's not dead you've
been using using Scott's unconscious Dreamscape
to deliver DVDs quicker Julie said you knew him
the longest when did you meet you told me you
were good at drawing real backstory draw me a
sheep that's the worst sheep I've ever seen
sheep is excellent oh no did she still love
him there was this one time I was kidnapped by
a rival school and Scott had to fight through an
entire Army of teen jerks and their leader
Simon Lee to rescue me S that's a romantic
memory how romantic can a memory be if things
ended terribly I love how he's got this whole
backstory of being this season fighter it's
like badass yeah why does this always happen
to me I don't know maybe you could ask one of
your seven evil exes this is unexpected well
you better get better at expecting you're
Roxy RoR Ramona's fourth evil X is Ramona
gonna fight oh I guess maybe she has to I'm
here for us Ramona first in line to win your
heart because I have something the others
never will oh emotional intelligence cuz a
woman man you're just impossible to talk
to you want to talk about feelings start
talking oh damn they're really hashing this
out let's fight about himor flowers she's so
reluctant are we really doing this again wa again
what the hell nice with the Mallet I respect the
Mallet whoa damn oh there's some sexual
tension here doing the Black Widow
thing oh this is how DVD stores came to be
destroyed come on wa how f on
oo movie hopping into all these
other typs of films that's so
cool it really looks like the Matrix or
something that's
cheap Oh Be Kind Rewind
took a lot of slashes for that
remote control yes do the whole
video store did Young Neil WR this fight sequence
I kill her yes
o they're just working [__] out
oh super old school animation I'm
sorry for what for leaving the way I did set her
free interesting using genra to
express the emotional state of
him now it's a silent film I was
too afraid to face you you made
me feel like nothing all I wanted
was for you to see me this has like
an Especial dubbed look but that
doesn't mean I'm going to let you
win save her Ramona oh damn sounded
painful or turn off the movie yeah what
are the rules switch to a kid's movie
whoa ouch ah oh man there's so much Cinema
here a as far as I'm concerned you won that's
what it's all about we were pretty immature
weren't we Ramona fighting her own ax how
woke really takes control of the narrative
from our man who needs character boost
you were really kicking my ass oh my God
they made a men saying that should we kiss
uh-uh he's dead Ramona it's complicated I've
got to find him first I'd like to be your
friend with benefits what about you oh I'm
not oh maybe try it
out wow go
for no saliva and everything everybody needs
closure that's why they call it closure now
you're one step closer to the dumb boy of your
dreams and you buried the hatchet with an ex
oh we're watching Ramona's story I guess so
I guess it's Ramona Flowers takes off don't
tell me I'm going to have to do this with
all seven of them we are watching Ramona's
story Scott Pilgrim takes off so Ramona
can deal with this [__] herself she's
going to deal with her ex's directly how
woke dude it's too woke for me is he evil
enough to kidnap a dude and fake his yeah
only one way to find out uhoh no account
video the robot what a wild show some bold
storytelling swings here G Eng Graves Gman
you don't remember me oh GID engraves
wasn't my birth name it was an identity
I created when I moved to New York City I
left my past behind and leveled up we're
going to strip him down you knew me
by another name sultry Suave Gordon
Gordon Goose from North Bay Ontario Gordon
go I've lost everything my Empire is gone my
billionaire friends have shunned me even
my millionaire friends have turned their
backs you still got those thousand dares
Gordon inv vitamin get your butt in here
a
it's like watching an alternate universe
Wolf Teen Scott it's about time there's
one thing I've been complaining
about is they haven't met their
Finn wolfart quoti John the next
episode's about to start oh 3 two 1
go who I have I have the same
same thing but with me shades
on and all oh another day on God's green baby oil
Earth wow that is very rich
Glendale California he lives at the
Americana oh my God his decks are so
righteous got a two tattoo whatever whatever
went down to the beach and S Ki she was
all like and I'm like what whatever I
haven't heard this song in a decade or
more how cool
Wicked Lucas Lee's Pro
Skater I think he is skating through
the American it's at least based on it
yeah well done nachos oh and this bar is totally
nearby that's my agent fellas agent chiz oh oh
it's El Coyote this town's on the verge of
saying see you later boy you are one mistake
away from movie jail Skater Boy good thing
I've got to get out a jail free card my ACT
is acting you want goody two shoes buy them
at a shoe store well that's just the sort of
thing that's made you nigh unemployable breaking
the dimensions your flight to Toronto departs in
4 hours you must be professional at every
opportunity or the stardom you love so much
will slip through your grasp what an interesting
inverse you love so giving them each some kind of
struggle whatever the First the movie Whatever
shouts out to Le Lynch the the movie has is
Cinema with a big spin on video games and
Anime and then the one that has the visual
of an anime and and video games is doing a lot
of Riff on Cinema yeah it's like what they did
with Brie Larson not singing the song instead
of Emily Haynes from last time it was really
funny they die this is how
every next episode begins
green and lighter green do
look poison
ivy T oh Toronto wood Toronto wood this
the set of the Lucas Lee movie without
explicit permission Lucas eel Lucas
Lee is here of course he's here what
do you think our job is do you know his
time F Nick Frost yeah as cops perfect
I recognized Nick Frost first actually
yeah same the same beat of that must be
S he's already working on a
stud oh it's look as starring in
his movie I'm just the writer of
this movie uh-huh you wrote a
movie Yes you wrote a Lucas Lee
movie oh no what oh no weird why is Envy Adams
dressed like me she's playing Ramona Flowers
What's the title of this movie Scott Pilgrim
takes off Scott Pilgrim's precious little life
you wrote an entire script about
a world where Scott Pilgrim won
the fight with Matthew Patel basically whoa cookie
meta oh great Audrey 2 Godzilla did you know in
the US these are called Mario Karts that can't
be true nuns nuns like a raptor oh well they're
called that pretty sure that's not true either
oh my God now just an amalgamation ET if there's
one story where makes sense to do a flip on who
you're going to focus on it would be the one who's
like directly connected to the X's yeah totally
Crush yes we need to talk about Scott
Pilgrim I'm Scott Pilgrim no the real
Scott Pilgrim you saying I'm a fake
Scott Pilgrim we're about to shoot my
first scene got to give the people what
they want Crank That Lucas Lee charm to
11 are you hitting on me maybe I am and maybe I
am oh my Lord oh golly
yeah careful careful I had a dream about that
girl again I care even less now hey how was
that uh gay enough any notes how about you build
a time machine go back in time and never audition
for this part in the first place who has the nerve
to share his opinions on the set of my film yes me
what your name I'm well as Wells method wow well
as Wells is just so like method wow how'd you know
exactly what Scott and I said in bed that morning
the creative process is a mystery Scott was the
one I hear Mr Lee is already balls deep in a
sweaty affair with someone on the production Envy
Adams gossip on who the lucky lady might be not
the mystery I'm trying to solve I'm reading the
script I'm busy come back later I'm not falling
for that I know you have a girl in there can we
just get this over with get what over with oh
he's actually reading the script did you know
I'm in this yeah you're the lead no there's a
Lucas Lee character and Scott tricks him into
grinding to death I'd never fall for that what
kind of idiot would write this yeah that's right
who who put that garbage can there that's his
coffee Young Neil may not be the brightest
but he has a vivid imagination the ending is
unrealistic the Ramona Flowers I know would
be on to the next one that was a long time ago
how interesting Scott's not dead someone wants
us to think he is who that's what I'm trying
to find out you think I'd kidnap some Canadian
loser and fake his death maybe you want a
quest to find a guy who was dating a high
schooler I'd never do anything that stupid if
I did my career would be over Lucas H what my
God what the the actor playing Scott Pilgrim
is dating an actress playing a high schooler
oh God you're dating a 17-year-old
she's 31 in real life act's playing
high schooler an earthquake in Toronto no
something worse oh got to work together
paparazzi
cool way to do this lighting
trick Lucas yes M twist
him we have you surrounded after scum show
yourself it's like an Animaniac
bit they're actually filming
whatever Luc Le verus the hell
yeah nice oh now we're in game
mode whoa great oh they're like a
smoke yep wck those bonus points of combos
mayy damn
what a Jurassic Park skeleton Jurassic
Le oh
jaw oh
damn I love this this is brilliant feels like an
old school arcade game oh my God God yes bonus
points
sweet take photos of your demise
yes no they can skate is there m
multiples of them or one that's
super fast oh that fishy even
got Escape video culture in
there some old school anime
[__]
wow that's agent yeah probably yeah
that's what it looked like need an
assist why would you help me what
do you mean I always helped you oh
oh my God she taught him how to grind
down the pole yes she was the skate
coach damn Ramona you broke so many hearts
until you left me with nothing but a broken
heart all the healing You' done until that point
he became who he is because of her was the day I
decided who I was going to be the best skater
the highest paid actor the biggest star all
clear I just got off with my agent I'm off
the movie and she's dumping me as a client
o maybe this will all blow over nah they're
already testing new actors to play Scott by
tomorrow morning someone else will be Cas
in the role of the guy you like more than
me and I'll be back to being nobody I wonder
who it'll be the Brandon Ralph one still think
I kidnapped the real scottt Pilgrim no
I don't see you as a kidnapping guy or
a portal guy because I didn't that was the
night of the Teen sorcerer Ford premere in
La
whoa this kid lands on his feet
though
portal all this vegan vegan Powers
vegan portals vegan portals and I'm
here to audition for the part of
Scott Pilgrim well good luck watch
out guys vegan coming through as
it should be yes we nailed it yeah
buddy Brandon Ralph up next let's go let's go
vegan police wow wow wow wow wow wow that was
pretty great continuously you know what's
fun we're watching this on Netflix oh is
it on Netflix it's on Netflix and I I also know
that if you're able to change your location How
would how would you do that you could I mean
first I should probably tell you that if you
change your location you don't just go how would
you do that let me finish what you want to do is
then you change yeah yeah wow terrible I'm just
so excited play the ad big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years
so whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum showing down
my internet and contacted me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my Express Fe on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix ULU BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new
shows use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn for
free that's expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more thank you
again well John did you love it I did I've been
loving this consistently Are People obset Are
People annoyed I've been seeing the word woke
go around I didn't know why I didn't know why it
was going around and then it dawned on me in the
LA in the Roxy episode of okay I get it because
this is rona's Adventure now yeah and Scott's
probably not going to return until like the end
of the series unless they subvert our expect yet
again I mean I can understand though that that is
a big ask of people yeah the title character is
gone it is I'm not UPS I'm not upset it is it is
a like oh what a shift be when you go from your
first episode to really riffing off of the movie
to then go just kidding pull pulling the rug out
underneath you we are significantly subverting
expectations and it would be a waste of time if
they were just doing an adaptation of the movie
yeah so to do a a different perspective on it is
a really interesting thing cuz it's more than just
pulling back the curtain more it's more than just
getting some backstory on on characters we didn't
get before it completely changes the way the plot
unfolds it's like it's still the the setup of
Ramona having to deal with uh her seven exes
but now there's a different purpose a different
Drive behind it and and it's a it becomes this
commentary to on a lot of things that is very very
meta in its own way while staying very true to the
execution of everything it's aiming to evoke in
terms of its animation period and style like it
really does feel like they're not trying to be
this era it it feels like it is this era yeah
um that just happens to have these modern day
settings to it a reasonably modern day like a
few years ago you know yeah yeah yeah uh which
which I think is really cool and then it's got
more of a a sweetness and more of a closure to
it versus I just got to like fight these people
and win it's a completely different kind of plot
because Ramona has to uh find resolve with that
that's usually the solution with it while leading
to some fun video game fight levels with the Roxy
and the different genre hopping around like
a Looney Tunes episode and then with um Lucas
Lee feeling like an arcade game you know like
Ninja Turtles or Simpsons with fighting people
with skateboards totally yeah so uh but it's
still fun and it's different it's a different
ask and and I it it is a I can see why it could
there's an audience that could be uh challenged
to get on board for for for it but I I personally
like it I do I'm looking forward to seeing how How
It ultimately concludes but it would feel like a
waste of time if it was just a Nostalgia it would
just feel yeah a fun excuse to get everybody back
together whereas this is like oh it's riding on
more than it's not resting on that alone yeah
yeah it's not there's an actual exploration of
of different things to do do while being able to
actually give us completely different scenes and
and locations to deal with while being while being
like funny and and taking the piss out of itself
yeah like it doesn't it's very expressive but it
doesn't feel like pretentiously deep in any way no
I I haven't read much at all about this just to
keep the experience fresh but I did see a small
quote from Brian Leo Mali kind of addressing like
you know I wanted to go back to this and not just
you know regurgitate it or you know do the whole
like like these things I wanted to come back and
kind of do I wanted to reflect on it so many years
later through kind of through what this is and you
know make it worthwhile in that way and I can
kind of see that because this has like a it's
like a tenderness of maturity almost because like
Scott M the way Scott's story is pitched it's very
much like you know a boy you know becoming less of
a boy and this is yeah pitching it I don't know it
makes a whole lot more like truly uh qualitative
emotional sense to have Ramona being the one who
is in this position and so it's like yeah she's
like clearing all this weight before at least as
it feels right now the goal is kind of clear all
this weight on the road to getting Scott back and
like you know obviously it's not in her mind as
structured as like I got to see them all you know
in finding them all she'll you know yeah release
all this probably right before finding him and I
think that's a really lovely thing to do and it
makes sense it gives her character I don't know
just like yeah more autonomy and it makes her less
of a device you know like a you know manic pixie
dream girl type like I like the character a lot
in the movie but I I am imagining you know what
you could there's just a much more boyish and
masculine perspective through that whereas this
is a bit more varied and I think authentically
so and I like the way that they characterize it
and to me it's it's like yeah it's it's it is a
big ask because it's the title character and so
much is about his journey love Michael Sarah in
that part but I think they're fortunate in the
fact that so much of this is a an ensemble and
B so much about the voice of its World more so
than just the specific character necessarily and
I mean there are many many Scott Pilgrim books
and and stories I I from what I understand beyond
the main one we know from the movie so like you
know I would have to imagine that if this season
is successful enough like I Scott would you know
be in a more fleshed out story if they were to
continue or whatever but for what this is here
and now uh yeah like I I I think it's really fun
and I haven't been it's not like they do a ton
to make him like super present but it's all about
finding him and what happened to him and they're
doing stuff with his story so it still feels like
Scott is represented even though he's not like on
on screen well some there there are parts of the
movie too that felt like you know the there there
this kind of self-awareness commentary that you
often see in in like certain comedies you see in
a lot of Marvel things that if like oh if they
just say it that immediately alleviates it when
shading you yeah yeah but that it that level of
self-awareness it's like just because you pointed
it out doesn't mean it's it's eliminated the issue
yeah and I think with the Scott Pilgrim movie
there were aspects as well I love it there were
aspects that the show itself seems to really be
acknowledging yeah of you know yeah they weren't
the best fleshed out moments of it and and and I
so I like the self-aware commentary on that while
still be you know what this kind of reminds you
have you seen the movie Brick yeah kind of reminds
me of brick yeah a little bit that yeah yeah not
not teen sleuth but yeah like sort of amateur
youth youth sleuth yeah young adult film new war
that seems to be a movie junkie kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah with a lot of genre splicing happening
um but but in it's like animated medium yeah I
I like it it's fun and yeah I mean I'm overall
I'm I'm satisfied as I like the I like how
it doesn't also paint Ramona as you get these
like tonal insights into parts of their with the
flashback stuff that's not really laying it down
thick on what made the relationship great it's
just how they that somberness when looking upon
the memories of their last moments together with
Roxy with Lucas Lee and a couple brief fleeting
glimpses of like what the you know what it was
like good what the romance was like yeah yeah but
it's also acknowledging a lot of the uh attachment
issues that Ramona herself even runs into and I
I even like the the again the self-awareness
of Ramona being like yeah no Scott's not my
boyfriend and we only went on one date but
it sure was a memory for me and it's like as
she's on revisiting these memories of people who
couldn't let her go she can't let Scott go yeah
you know so there is a cool mirror effect there
yeah they're doing a lot of nice yeah mirroring
and complimenting of things and uh and too I
I just you know I think I like that thing that
you pointed out that this being I like that too
yeah then you know what I'm going to say and we
don't I don't even need to like hear it honestly
I know exactly what you're getting at CU I don't
only said one thing so I just I could just assume
was that one thing that one comment when you were
like you laughed and yeah it was I too yeah say
it again you said the thing about the movie having
yeah the movie being you know bringing all this
to live action has so many flourishes and ODS to
the styles of animation and whatnot and I think
the way they've taken that baton and run with it
is very fun and as you you know expound it it it
it flips that and and does a lot of film styling
and video game styling on top of this animated
medium and so like I did say having the prospect
that each set of x's will bring their own kind of
thing is nice and and that was true of the movie
too but here yeah you had that Montage of like
all the different kinds of movies with all the
different color grading and film grains and stuff
like that and you have the whole like spending
time like it really reminded me of Animaniacs in
the second episode just spending time on the lot
and all the gags and Young Neil becoming a scream
screen writer I like young NE and then when Lucas
Lee has his fight like there's so many skateboard
game Traditions thrown in there it's like you have
the ones that are like oh some kind of downhill
slalom thing or the ones that are yeah like The
Simpsons or skater die or or you know even jouster
or stuff like that where yeah you were doing like
skateboard melee stuff and yeah and uh yeah like
they managed to smoosh all those things together
in one sequence sure that you know kind of exists
as its own on on just like a I don't know it's a
great little you know animated interlude but
it's yeah clearly kind of I don't know very
very encompassing of much time in culture in a
in a fun and impressive way in ways that that
you can enjoy without having all the touchstones
but if you've got some or most of them then it's
even more rich and I think that's kind of a nice
thing about this too is like there are a broad
array of random different little Easter egg things
that are just like I don't know I think it's just
because it's a a back lot and it's not like one
specific franchise it feels a little less lurid
it feels a little more fun when you can just be
like oh here's a bunch of [__] that would be on
a back ladder let's do one of those gags where
you're on a mural or a you know mat painting
and then you know someone bursts through it and
we pull out and we find out that we're still on
the back lot like yeah yeah there's so many
great like film flourishes and I just adore
that within one episode Young Neil is a full on
screen writer full a Hollywood dream yeah totally
and we got our assignment wres it overnight I'm
a writer I'm a writer and S neck Frost without
Edgar right actually directing we're never going
to get that Reunion yeah no more cornettos all
righty guys well do you think Scott Pilgrim takes
off as a woke garbage that Hollywood is making
Jam thought down below uh be sure to subscribe
leave a like and thank you to express mepn and we
will chitchat with everyone here relatively soon
thank you for being here with us on this journey
by